[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen rudizan ist auch dabei für
den Sport hallo schönen guten Abend
schauen wir auf die Themen von heute
Ampel Streit in Berlin SPD FDP und Grüne
Ringen um Kompromisse beim Klimaschutz
und bei Verkehrsprojekten
Deutschland vor dem megawarenstreik
Riesen Andrang am Flughafen Düsseldorf
Airport München war schon heute dicht
und Neustart nach WM Debakel nachdem sie
gegen Peru spielt die DFB-Elf am
Dienstag gegen Belgien
[Applaus]
seit einer halben Stunde beraten die
Spitzen der Koalition fast 20 Leute im
Kanzleramt da hat sich im Dreier Bündnis
einiges angestaut an Vorwürfen und
schlechter Stimmung und an Probleme beim
Klimaschutz liegen FDP und Grüne weit
auseinander zu dem gibt es nicht genug
Geld für alle Wünsche Klaus brodbecker
Details
draußen demonstrieren sie für
Klimaschutz gegen die die in ihre
Ansicht nach nicht ernst genug nehmen
und drinnen gleich verhandeln werden zum
Beispiel der Chef der SPD hier wortkarig
gute Sitzung
wochenlang hatten sich die
ampelkoalitionäre gegenseitig behagt
auch intern mehren sich nun Appelle zu
vernünftigem Arbeitsklima zurückzukehren
in den letzten Wochen ging es wenn man
ehrlich ist ein bisschen ruppig zu auch
ruppiger als es sein sollte am Ende
haben wir beim letzten Jahr immer wieder
bewiesen dass dort wo es wirklich darauf
ankommt wenn es um die Energiekrise ging
wenn es um die vielen entlastungspakete
ging die gemacht haben um Menschen zu
helfen wir alle gemeinsam fürs Land da
sind es dürfte gestritten werden über
planungsbeschleunigung etwa und darüber
ob der Straßenverkehr also Autobahnen
davon stärker profitieren soll oder die
Bahn über Heizungen eine Art abfragt
Prämie für klimaschädlinge wie einst für
alte Autos scheint denkbar statt eines
Verbots und natürlich ums Geld der
Haushalt steht noch immer nicht die
Opposition ungeduldig wir erwarten uns
mehr als ein kleinen Sprung es brauchte
es wirklich eine neue Dynamik der dauert
der belastet ja nicht nur die Ampel er
schade Deutschland das was jetzt läuft
dass man überhaupt nicht weiß wie die
nächsten Schritte sein werden das
verunsichert die Menschen gerade erst
haben sie begonnen Ende und Ergebnisse
ziemlich offen
ja fragen wir Theo Koll in Berlin was
ist da heute zu erwarten tatsächlich ein
kleiner Sprung nach vorn wie das der
Bundeskanzler hofft
ja genau der Bundeskanzler sprach ja
auch nur von einem kleinen Sprung und
das sollte wohl zu schaffen sein
jedenfalls nachdem was ich jetzt von
mehreren Seiten gehört habe eines der
Kernthemen heute ist die
planungsbeschleunigung da gibt es
offensichtlich Verhandlungsbereitschaft
und auch schon ein fast fertiges Papier
es könnte dann am Ende heißen die FDP
und ihr Verkehrsminister bekommen die
Zusage dass einige sehr wesentliche
autobahnstücke beschleunigt gebaut
werden dürfen die Grünen fordern im
Gegenzug dass der Verkehrsminister
insgesamt beim Einhalten der
Klimaschutzziele entscheiden voran kommt
auch beim Thema Heizungen scheinen sich
die Unterhändler näher gekommen zu sein
da gibt es in den kommenden Tagen
offensichtlich weitere Gespräche auch
zur Frage wie die Umstellung sozial
abgefedert werden kann ob mit einer
abfragt-prämie die ja dann Arm und Reich
gleich unterstützt oder sozial
gestaffelt in jedem Fall genug Stoff für
eine sehr lange Nachtsitzung danke schön
für diese Information live aus Berlin
deine theoroll
der von Verdi und Bahngewerkschaft EVG
angekündigte waren Streik wird morgen
weite Teile des öffentlichen Verkehrs
lahmlegen erste Auswirkungen sind längst
zu spüren zum Beispiel fahren schon
jetzt keine Züge mehr die ihr Ziel erst
nach Mitternacht also nach Streik
beginnt erreichen Christian Volk über
den Tag davor
schnell weg solange es noch geht das
denken sich viele auch am Düsseldorfer
Flughafen tausende versuchen vor dem
bundesweiten Warnstreik noch in den
Urlaub oder zur nächsten Konferenz zu
kommen wir haben diese Woche
Veranstaltungen in Madrid und ich wäre
eigentlich morgen geflogen und jetzt
fliegen wir halt heute um das zu umgehen
wir haben uns überlegt lieber sonntags
zu buchen weil im Vorfeld ja schon
bekannt war dass Tarifverhandlungen sind
und da Sonntag ist uninteressant zum
streiken weil die ganzen
geschäftstätigen die Fliegen natürlich
aber mitten in der Woche ganz anders am
Flughafen in München hier ist Zeit zum
durchwischen das Bodenpersonal streikt
bereits heute alle geplanten Flüge
fallen aus Reisende wechseln etwa aufs
Auto ohne Verkehrschaos für LKW ist in
Bayern zwar das Sonntagsfahrverbot
aufgehoben viele Trucker müssen dennoch
stehen bleiben weil sie ihre maximale
Wochenarbeitszeit schon erfüllt haben
der Wirtschaft so Experten wird das und
der bundesweite Streik nicht viel
anhaben viele Arbeit wird es nach wie
vor Geschehen eben nicht von denen die
jetzt nicht reisen können aber von zu
Hause aus oder es gibt nachholeffekte
ich glaube also dieser eine Tag wird
hier keinen Schaden weder für ein
Unternehmen noch für die Volkswirtschaft
das ganze verursachen auch am
Hauptbahnhof in München planen Sie um
fahren früher oder geben ihr Ticket
zurück bereits jetzt fallen die ersten
Fernzüge etwa nach Köln Berlin oder
Hamburg aus
die Ankündigung von russlands Präsident
Putin Atomwaffen im Nachbarland Belarus
zu stationieren ist bei der
Bundesregierung auf Kritik gestoßen das
Auswärtige Amt nannte Putins Vorgehen
einen weiteren Versuch der nuklearen
Einschüchterung Putins Aussage Russland
machen nur das was die USA in Europa
seit Jahrzehnten machten sei ihre
führend dieses in Berlin
putinskrieg in der Ukraine fordert jeden
Tag mehr leben vor allem Soldaten
sterben im ganzen Land müssen Friedhöfe
ständig erweitert werden Tod und Trauer
sind in vielen ukrainischen Familien
präsent die Gräber der Angehörigen oft
noch ganz frisch unsere Reporterin eine
Brühl hat mit trauernden gesprochen in
20 als er starb
alle 26
poleschko 21 sie alle haben für ihr Land
als Soldaten gekämpft auf dem Friedhof
in hakif gibt es viele Soldatengräber
hunderte über jedem wird die ukrainische
Flagge
sehen Sie wie viele unserer Soldaten
gefallen sind in diesem Krieg ich will
dass dieser Preis nicht umsonst ist
in der Ukraine bringen Angehörige in der
Fastenzeit Brot und Süßigkeiten zu den
Gräbern für die Verstorbenen Irina ist
mit ihrem Sohn gekommen ihr Mann war
Grenzsoldat
es gibt viele solcher Friedhöfe überall
in der Ukraine
das ist schrecklich und das ist Zeit
diesen Krieg zu beenden denn es gibt zu
viele Ukraine
die nächste Trauergesellschaft wartet
schon für einen 26-jährigen denn bachmut
getötet wurde
die Tornados in den USA haben vor allem
im Süden des Landes heftige Schäden
hinterlassen mindestens 26 Menschen
starben im US-Staat Mississippi wurden
ganze Stadtteile dem Erdboden gleich
gemacht nach Böen von bis zu 320
Kilometern pro Stunde rief die
US-Regierung dort den Ausnahmezustand
aus der Wiederaufbau wird nach
Einschätzung von Experten Jahre dauern
und jetzt zur Fußballnationalmannschaft
Rudi das lief gestern ganz gut oder kann
man so sagen auf jeden Fall erster Test
des Jahres geglückt Deutschland schlägt
Peru 2:0 beim nächsten Auftritt
übermorgen gegen Belgien in Köln muss
Bundestrainer Hans seine Start 11
umbauen Kai havertz fehlt wegen eines
grippalen infektions Nico Schlotterbeck
pausiert wegen muskulärer Probleme
gestern der Matchwinner Niklas Füllkrug
mit seinen beiden Toren ein Tor Garant
auf zwei Beinen für Niklas Füllkrug
steht der heutige Sonntag im Zeichen der
fanpflege der Bremer gestern Matchwinner
beim glanzlosen aber souveränen Sieg der
Mittelstürmer bestätigte mit einem
Doppelpack seine starke Form seine
Bilanz 5 Treffer in fünf Länderspielen
die Nummer 9 setzt beim Neuanfang
positive Signal
das erste Länderspiel 2320 gewonnen ein
Heimspiel was uns freut
Füllkrug zählte zu den wenigen
Lichtblicken beim durchwachsenen 2.0 bis
zur erhofften Aufbruchstimmung ist es
noch ein weiter Weg
Katharina Hennig hat zum Saisonfinale
zum achten Mal in ihrer Karriere einen
Podestplatz erreicht die Olympiasiegerin
im Teamsprint belegte in Finnland beim
Massenstart über 20 km im klassischen
Stil den dritten Rang und beendete ihre
Langlaufsaison als gesamte im Weltcup
der Tages-
und beim letzten Saison Weltcup der
Nordischen Kombinierer stand nicht der
Gewinner im Mittelpunkt sondern Eric
Frenzel obwohl er nur 40 da wurde und
seine Kollegen standen für ihn verlieren
der 34-Jährige beendete nach gut 16
Jahren im Weltcup seine profikariere
dreimal olympisches Gold sieben WM Titel
und fünf Mal den Gesamtweltcup Gewand
Frenzel und wurde von seinem Team als
größter aller Zeiten gefeiert im Tages
auch noch übrigens ja Magnus Rewe aus
Norwegen
lass ihn feiern ja schöne Bilder
Dankeschön fehlt noch der Blick aufs
Wetter ein Mix aus vielen Wolken und
etwas Sonne dazu immer wieder
Schneeregen und Graupelschauer Gewitter
sind auch dabei an den Alpen länger
Schnee bei einem lebhaften Nordwestwind
ein bis acht Grad
das heute journal um 9:45 Uhr mit
Marietta Slomka wir sagen danke und
tschüss und geben direkt weiter an Theo
Koll nach Berlin